Charlie it's Oh Charlie yes so Charlie
is so cool you tell well this is it
could be chinga it could be blue tack
you just don't know
okay it's blue tiger I'm gonna put this
down you know a while ago I said that I
was doing a play called bear wolf play
is called bill and I also said that I'd
be making a video behind the scenes of
bear wolf like Cameron recorder that was
quite a while ago and I still haven't
managed to do that yet don't blame me
blame my friend blame Chloe senior who
stars in something the video files here
but she will do
won't you Chloe I've actually started
doing another play now what started
rehearsals for another player but my
script here magically hidden I'm doing
Philip Pullman's His Dark Materials
quite a chunky script to be honest the
play is about three hours long just a
bit annoying and oh well sorry I'm
hiding some of the text part one two
three hour-long plays both played on the
same night that means six hours of
acting a night I've even got two
separate folders organization luckily I
managed to get a bit of a better part
this time around
my character is Jabari and I actually
died in the play which is pretty cool
what's even cooler is that even though
I've died I still come back in the land
of the dead so even though I've died I
still get lines after I've died this is
pretty sweet I have a nice little speech
look see it's all highlighted this was
the result it worked it worked
triumphant Lee but they unleash the
power they can control the knife could
cut windows into other worlds and then
the specters floated in yeah take it I
don't have a kind of nerdy confession to
make I've managed to resist the
temptation to get World of Warcraft
until now I haven't properly got it yet
okay so I'm not super nerd I'm
downloading the free trial at the moment
pretty much halfway and only about four
hours to go
Oh actually while we're here you might
as well look at my wallpaper it's pretty
cool isn't it I'll put a link in the
video description so you can download
that for yourself what color top am I
wearing you don't know as far as you're
concerned it's a great op as far as
you're concerned my face is gray maybe I
should put this down well the reason I'm
wearing my hat today is because of my
hair it feels really really weird we
didn't have any like normal shampoo so I
just kind of grabbed the nearest bottle
of shampoo that we could find and now
all my hair feels all silky and
manageable I'm not sure if I like it or
not to be honest so I'm wearing a hat
okay I'm sure you wanted to know that I
don't know what to talk about I do have
something to show you actually a few of
you mentioned this little chap down here
why do you have a headless dog in the
background it's absolutely a piggy bank
you can see from there but it's in the
shape of a dog lens cleaner a bi rope em
a little wrist and thing some adapters a
little bit of rubbish and now laser
crowns have just gone on my laptop and
seeing as we're going through things on
my little shelf today I thought I'd show
you this as well some of you have wanted
to see baby pictures of me so there you
go that's me as a baby and quite a cool
little photo stand doo doo doo doo
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo
I think it's quite cool what do you want
me to do I'm not here to entertain you
I'm here because I'm bored right I don't
care what you people think I do
I do care please don't unsubscribe
that's quite easy to scare people on
this website isn't it I mean people do
it all the time like it's just
concentrate on something like a nice
spot or something like that and then all
of a sudden freaky huh this is a mask
that was actually used for bear wolf
actually for one of the warrior dead
people or something why am I still in
color that's better time to end the
video there I guess see ya we need to be
bad by telling Toby bye bye Danny w bye
bye goodbye
I almost forgot on the first of October
I am going to be 17 years old your time
to make birthday collaboration videos is
running out Thea first of October